a lot of times when we're talking about
this prediction X effort in in many
different venues people say oh you must
be doing a lot about astrology because
they know I'm an astronomer and I say no
actually I know nothing about astrology
but given how many people are very very
interested in their own horoscope today
and people have been interested in that
for generations we've really thought it
was important to include an expert
astrologer modern astrologer in the
course not Isaac Newton who's an expert
old astrologer when I think of astrology
I think it's man in astronomy mm-hmm you
know it's this kind of how it might
affect that person yeah those those
planets around the person so when we
look at a child we are looking at the
center as if you were standing in the
center in the center's earth okay okay
so obviously you know the socialism's
the heliocentric right but when we look
at it we're looking at from you on the
earth and what those planets are
symbolizing about youth is there any
kind of like physical connection between
the actual pull of planets for example
on a person and what what is forecast
for them everything's interconnected
okay and so that's my sense and and that
the movements do affect us and I'm not
sure what it is but I can tell you after
years of working with people in charts
it's uncanny
what a chart reveals and what the
movements of the planets their stars can
say about the person without me very
curious so it's okay I'm not sure what
the exact connection I know there's a
connection okay you know and from from
observation personal observation right
you know not just going on faith but
that this is this is amazing how you
know certain things just come so a lot
of it is like people have done this kind
of astrology for thousands of years and
McCord's in your mouth but but this kind
of learned more and more about what kind
that things you can predict
the positions of planets exactly I think
a lot of this is in some ways pattern
recognition you know when you have
certain combinations certain things tend
to happen and it know what the same
things happen for all people born at the
same time in the same place no and
that's what becomes that that's where
it's interesting so I was just gonna say
I I don't believe that everything set in
stone you know I believe that there's
basic patterns and then we have this
free will to move within these patterns
okay so you'll see some people with a
certain configuration that's very
pronounced and you know that person is
going to be very successful they can do
and maybe that doesn't fully
materialized and then that somebody else
were not born and that date at that
place place is important to at that time
which is very important the time they
may completely you know fulfill that
potential that we're reading got in the
chart astrology because it's so
intricate is about the relationships
between that planet and the sign which
means the part of the sky it was in and
how it's relating to the other planets
in relating to earth in a particular
time or a particular day in particular
place
what would you say is the balance among
your clients of people who are very
seriously looking to you for advice
about you know business decisions in
their love life and whatever and and
then other people who are just kind of
curious and want to have the experience
of knowing their horoscope in my in my
practice yes I would say I'm about
eighty eighty-five percent more serious
okay guidance and maybe fifteen to
twenty percent or more of the curious
got it
yeah whose give people bad news well I
don't look at anything as bad or good I
look at it all his energy I'll tell
people what to look for
okay yeah I can tell when there's going
to be a lot of change okay I can tell
when somebody's going to go they're
gonna need to let something big go
mm-hmm okay so I can tell if there's
something going on maybe it was Pluto
working or or Saturn aspecting Pluto
that they're gonna have to let a way of
being go or there's some aspect of there
style that needs to change and my
feeling is I'm kind of an optimist
anyway but my feeling is is that how I
read astrology is it's a way to
understand ourselves in our lives and to
help us mm-hmm so if there are the more
difficult or you're saying bad or
challenging aspects I ultimately see it
from the big picture is trying to help
us evolve given that we're talking about
this being the long tradition that
people didn't know Pluto was even there
or that it was a planet or a dwarf
planet or whatever we want to call it
yeah yeah something in the solar system
does it have new significance because it
exists or well I understand your
question so yeah we didn't read the
three outer planets right until the last
150 years or so and so we wouldn't have
looked at that probably his aspect in
Pluto this is your map of you okay and
then as you know this is your universe
this is giving me like a like a Polaroid
okay of what was in the sky okay okay
and so when you were born and we need
the place the date but we need the time
to be really accurate because as you
know you know the the plans for Zane 24
hours so what's coming up over the
horizon is changing every two hours
roughly and that's called your ascendant
mm-hmm this sets the tone of the whole
chart so what's rising in the sky is
setting the whole tone for you in terms
of how it's like the lens you see life
through okay that's called your
ascendant or rising sign okay your
rising sign is Libra and Libra is an air
sign so this is more than working with
the intellect mm-hmm
Libra is also about balance libras the
scales mm-hmm right so we have balance
we have diplomacy
it's very partnership oriented wanting
to work together with other people in
teams so the houses are fields of
influence in your case 9th house appear
the top of the chart is representing
higher education it's representing
developing the mind it's representing
or in travel is its span ssin of what's
possible in the world so let me back up
for a second so this is about what we've
been saying is about sort of kind of
person I might be looking at a
personality I have and then does this
kind of horoscope get more specific
about events that are an absolutely
future or just people's tendencies no we
can we do both okay so this is your your
map this is your star map this is this
is giving me a blueprint this is your
baked basic makeup okay the K is an
astrologer to look at it this is
permanent for you so then what we do is
we can look at any particular time in a
person's life okay now when people come
to see me they were they're usually
looking at what's going on now or maybe
this next year or you know roughly at
this time and so I do what's called a
transit there's different things you can
do I do a transits chart because it's
most literal it's literally where the
planets are and transiting you know in
the in the orbit and how they maybe
aspect in your birth chart so what we do
is when we look at predictions mm-hmm
we're looking at what is that nature and
what may be aspect in it may be what
what is what is what's another word I
can use for that what is playing on it
okay so basically it's another way is
saying what's up for you okay yeah
what's up what's up for you one of the
things that does jump at me is that
you've had your on this is your honest
and Aries it's been an area since about
March the planet you're honest has been
in Aries and I think March 2011 okay so
about seven years sits in there
yeah 84 year orbit and it is working its
way through your seventh house what that
tells me without knowing you is this
could be very interesting good news for
your love life mhm and because you're
honest in Aries is is wanting to you're
honest is we call it the awakener
mmm-hmm okay we call it the awakener or
the rejuvenator and it's in the Aries
it's like wanting new energy new actions
sounds great I have
a lot of decisions to make about how
many long trips to go on in the next six
months or so okay and it could be
anywhere from about three to about six
and six seems like kind of too much and
is there any reason I should go on every
trip that I could go on so I can see
that more opportunities are coming to
you and me no question and there's an in
travel would be one of them however you
don't have to take everything that comes
along and and in there's more of a
relaxing into some of this it's in your
here's one thing I'm going to tell you
for sure mm-hmm
is you need to trust your intuition or
and I'm not just saying that as a
blanket statement I'm saying that to you
because you have planets lining up in
such a way that are suggesting that your
ear intuition is opening even more this
could even indicate like a like a
spiritual opening some sort you know a
it could be through religious study it
could be through an experience but it's
a spiritual opening it's an opening than
that consciousness this is indicating a
lot of intuition you already are
extremely intuitive based on your birth
chart and this is tied to the travel
question okay so this is I'm not going
to say taking it easier let me find the
words for you more time at the spa yes
[Music]
you